Well, I haven't seen the actual lab yet. My doctor sister was called by lab corps that I am ademic and I heard was very low, not so low for your visit.
So what they'll, your visit if you're, if I heard is low, they'll look at your hemoglobin, so if your hemoglobin is below 7.5, then you do need to get in and get a transfusion.
If your hemoglobin is still 10, but your iron is low, your red blood cell count is low, then you don't need an infusion, but then you do have to think of supporting the low iron.
Also, in your case, and you have to look at, is there any possible bleeding because of your type of cancer.
So you always want to, whatever you have ademia, you always want to ask, whatever you have anything you want to ask the question, what question? Why? Why? Why?
Can you have anemia in cancer? Because the, because cancer is gobbling up, some higher? Yes, you can.
Can you have anemia, anemia in, for any reason, because you have, you're losing red blood cells through bleeding? Yes.
So, you do want to investigate that. Maybe want to do, it'll call blood test, which is a blood, which is a swab stool sample swab called a little blood test for that.
It's very simple, and see if there's any, if that's a cause, so we need to look at that.
But not a low enough, they called also my B12 was low. I do have a partial empty HFR defect. This is the first time she has ever called by a lab with a warning for a patient.
So the B12 being low, that would be a concern to, you could have B12 with anemia. That would be good. It would be better. It's better.
It's easier to correct. He needs a B12 would be just fine. I would suggest the hydroxyl cobalt amate.
Or the adenosyl cobalt amate. Besides eating liver, et cetera. I noticed there are products aligned for ancestral and heart, soil, where they have freeze dried grass fed blood liver, spleen, bovine products.
I've seen I got some. I think those are fine. Any other suggestions. Sorry, don't have actual lab results yet. Not sure what is driving this. I was having blood in stool regularly, but since June 15th, I've only seen it twice.
So let's see those labs and then we'll go from there, glyphosate 2.5. That's just very frustrating with the glyphosate.